y esta gráfica es solo hasta 2021.
Se pondrá muy, muy feo a partir de 2030.
Y esta gráfica trata de resumir el problema.
Los demócratas, dicen, bueno, no es una gran cosa.
Podemos subir los impuestos un poco y cerramos la brecha,
especialmente si subimos los de los ricos.
Los republicanos dicen, no, no, tenemos una mejor idea.
¿Por qué no bajamos las dos líneas?
¿Por qué no bajamos el gasto del gobierno y bajamos los impuestos,
y entonces estaremos en una trayectoria aún más
favorable del déficit en el largo plazo?
Y detrás de este poderoso desacuerdo sobre
cómo cerrar la brecha,
está la peor clase de cinismo de los partidos políticos,
la peor clase de miembro del grupo, el lobby, toda la parafernalia,
pero hay además intereses poderosos,
respetuoso desacuerdo entre
dos filosofías económicas fundamentalmente diferentes.
Y me gusta pensar, cuando imagino cómo ven la economía
los republicanos, imagino una asombrosa
máquina bien diseñada, cierto tipo de perfección.
Desafortunadamente, es un cuadro hecho en Alemania o Japón,
pero esta máquina asombrosa que constantemente elimina
todo el esfuerzo humano e insume los recursos,
dinero, trabajo, capital, maquinaria,
lejos de las zonas menos productivas y las lleva a las zonas más productivos,
y aunque esto pueda causar perturbación temporal,
lo que hace es construir unas áreas más productivas
y dejar las menos productivas desvanecerse y morir,
y como resultado todo el sistema es más eficiente,
más rico para todos.
Y esta visión generalmente cree que el papel del gobierno,
un papel reducido, es poner las reglas para que las personas no mientan
ni engañen, ni dañen unas a otras,
quizá, tener departamentos de policía y bomberos
y un ejército, pero un alcance muy limitado
en los mecanismos de esa maquinaria.
Y cuando imagino a los demócratas o a los economistas demócratas
inclinarse en esa dirección,
muchos economistas demócratas son, saben, capitalistas,
creen, sí, que es un buen sistema la mayor parte del tiempo.
Es bueno dejar que los mercados muevan los recursos a las áreas más productivas.
Pero el sistema tienen muchísimos problemas.
La riqueza se acumula en los lugares equivocados.
La riqueza se le quita a personas que no deberían ser llamadas improductivas.
Esto no creará una sociedad equitativa y justa.
A la máquina no le importa el ambiente,
el racismo, todos estos temas
que hacen la vida peor para todos,
y entonces el gobierno tiene el papel de tomar los recursos
de usos más productivos, de las fuentes más ricas,
para darlos a otras fuentes.
Y cuando pensamos en la economía a través de estos dos lentes diferentes,
uno entiende por qué es tan difícil de resolver esta crisis
debido a que cuanto mayor es la crisis, mayores serán las apuestas,
cuanto más, cada parte, crea que sabe la respuesta
y que el otro lado va a arruinarlo todo.
Y realmente me desespera. He pasado mucho tiempo
en los últimos años deprimido por esto,
hasta este año, en que me enteré de algo que
me hizo entusiasmarme mucho. Siento que es una muy buena noticia,
y es tan impactante, no me gusta decirlo, porque creo que
la gente no me cree.
Pero esto es lo que aprendí.
Los estadounidenses, considerados en su conjunto,
cuando se trata de estos temas, en cuestiones fiscales,
son moderados, centristas pragmáticos.
Y sé que es difícil de creer, que el pueblo estadounidense
es moderado, centrista pragmático.
Pero permítanme explicar a qué me refiero.
Si analizamos cómo gasta dinero el gobierno federal,
esta es la batalla aquí,
el 55 %, más de la mitad, va a la seguridad social,
Medicare, Medicaid, algunos otros programas de salud,
el 20 % en defensa, el 19 % discrecional,
y 6 % en intereses.
Así que al hablar de cortar el gasto del gobierno,
hablamos de esta tarta,
y los estadounidenses abrumadoramente, sin importar
de qué partido sean, mayoritariamente, les gusta
este gran 55 %.
Les gusta la seguridad social. Les gusta Medicare.
Incluso Medicaid, a pesar de que va a los pobres y a los indigentes,
que uno imaginaría que tendría menos apoyo.
Y fundamentalmente no quieren tocarlo,
aunque los estadounidenses están muy cómodos,
y los demócratas aproximadamente igualan a los republicanos,
en algunos ajustes menores para hacer el sistema más estable.
La seguridad social es bastante fácil de ajustar.
Los rumores de su desaparición son siempre muy exagerados.
Gradualmente se aumenta la edad de jubilación,
tal vez solo a personas que no han nacido aún.
Los estadounidenses están 50/50,
en si son demócratas o republicanos.
Reducir Medicare para las personas mayores muy ricas,
personas mayores que hacen mucho dinero. Incluso no eliminarlo. Solo reducirlo.
Las personas generalmente están cómodas con eso, demócratas y republicanos.
¿Recaudar contribuciones para cuidado médico?
Todo el mundo lo odia por igual, pero los republicanos
y los demócratas lo odian juntos.
Esto dice, cuando uno ve
la discusión de cómo resolver nuestros problemas fiscales,
que no somos una nación dividida profundamente respecto de los temas principales e importantes.
Estamos cómodos con que se necesitan algunos ajustes, pero queremos mantenerlo.
No estamos abiertos a la discusión de si eliminarlo.
Ahora hay un tema que es muy partidista,
y donde un partido solo quiere gastar, gastar, gastar,
no nos importa, gastar más
y son por supuesto los republicanos
cuando se trata de gasto en defensa militar.
Superan a los demócratas.
La gran mayoría quiere proteger el gasto de defensa militar.
Es el 20 % del presupuesto,
y presenta un problema más difícil.
También debo señalar que el gasto [discrecional],
aproximadamente el 19 % del presupuesto,
es tema de demócratas y republicanas,
así que tienen bienestar, cupones de alimento, otros programas
que tienden a ser populares entre los demócratas,
pero también cuentas del Departamento del Interior y todo tipo
de incentivos para la perforación de petróleo y otras cosas,
que tienden a ser populares entre los republicanos.
Ahora, en cuanto a impuestos, hay más desacuerdo.
Es una zona más partidista.
Tienen apoyo abrumador de los demócratas
en elevar el impuesto sobre la renta a las personas que ganan USD 250 000 al año,
los republicanos están en contra, aunque si los divides por ingresos,
a los republicanos que ganan menos de USD 75 000 al año les gusta la idea.
Pero, a los republicanos que ganan más de USD 250 000 al año no quieren más impuestos.
Al aumentar los impuestos sobre la renta de la inversión, también se observa que
cerca de dos tercios de los demócratas pero solo un tercio de los republicanos
están cómodos con esa idea.
Esto lleva a un punto realmente importante, que
en este país tendemos a hablar de los demócratas
y los republicanos y pensar que hay un pequeño grupo
de así llamados independientes que es, ¿qué?, ¿2 %?
Si sumamos a demócratas y republicanos,
tenemos a los estadounidenses.
Pero ese no es el caso en absoluto.
Y no ha sido el caso durante la mayor parte de la historia estadounidense moderna.
Aproximadamente un tercio de los estadounidenses dicen que son demócratas.
Alrededor de una cuarta parte dice que son republicanos.
Una pequeña astilla se llaman a sí mismos libertarios, o socialistas,
o algún otro pequeño tercer partido,
y el bloque más grande, 40 %, dice que es independiente.
Por lo que la mayoría de los estadounidenses no es partidista,
y la mayoría de la gente en el campo independiente
cae en algún lugar en el medio, por lo que incluso aunque tenemos
gran superposición entre las opiniones sobre estas cuestiones fiscales
de demócratas y republicanos,
tenemos superposición aún mayor al agregar a los independientes.
Ahora tenemos que luchar sobre todo tipo de asuntos.
Llegamos a odiarnos unos a otros sobre el control de armas
y el aborto y el medio ambiente,
pero en estas cuestiones fiscales, estas importantes cuestiones fiscales,
simplemente no estamos tan divididos como la gente dice.
Y, de hecho, existe este otro grupo de personas
que no está tan dividido como la gente podría pensar,
y es el grupo de economistas.
He hablado con muchos economistas y por allá por los 70
y los 80 era feo ser economista.
Estabas en lo que llamaban el campamento de agua salada,
Harvard, Princeton, MIT, Stanford, Berkeley,
o estabas en el campamento de agua dulce, Universidad de Chicago,
Universidad de Rochester.
Eras un economista capitalista de libre mercado
o eras un economista liberal keynesiano,
y estas personas no van a las bodas de los otros,
se desairaban mutuamente en las conferencias.
Es feo aún hoy en día, pero en mi experiencia,
realmente, es realmente difícil encontrar un economista menor de 40
que todavía tenga esa forma de ver el mundo.
La mayoría de los economistas... no es bueno
llamarte un ideólogo de cualquier campo.
La frase que quieres, si eres estudiante de postgrado
o postdoctorado o profesor,
un profesor de economía de 38 años dice: "Soy empirista.
Me baso en datos".
Y los datos están muy claros.
Ninguna de estas teorías principales ha sido completamente exitosa.
El siglo XX, los últimos cien años,
está plagado de ejemplos desastrosos
de veces en que una escuela u otra intentó explicar
el pasado o predecir el futuro
y acabo haciendo un trabajo horrible, horrible,
por lo que la profesión de economista ha adquirido cierto grado de modestia.
Todavía son un grupo de personas muy arrogantes, se lo aseguro,
pero ahora son arrogantes sobre su imparcialidad,
y también ven una enorme gama de posibles resultados.
Y este apartidismo es algo que existe,
ha existido en secreto
en EE.UU. durante años y años y años.
He pasado el otoño hablando con las tres organizaciones
principales que encuestan las actitudes políticas estadounidenses:
Pew Research,
el centro de investigación de opinión de nacional de la Universidad de Chicago,
y la más importante pero menos conocida,
el grupo de Estudios Estadounidense de Elección Nacional
que es la mayor encuesta de las actitudes políticas del mundo y la más respetada.
Han estado haciéndola desde 1948,
y lo que muestran consistentemente
es que es casi imposible encontrar estadounidenses
que concuerden ideológicamente,
que apoyen constantemente, "No, no necesitamos impuestos,
y debemos limitar el tamaño del gobierno",
o, "No, debemos alentar al gobierno a desempeñar un papel mayor
en la redistribución y corregir los males del capitalismo".
Esos grupos son muy, muy pequeños.
La gran mayoría de las personas deciden con cuidado,
transigen y cambian con el tiempo
al oír un mejor argumento o un argumento peor.
Y eso no ha cambiado.
Lo que ha cambiado es cómo las personas responden a preguntas vagas.
Si uno hace preguntas vagas, como,
"¿Cree que debería haber más gobierno o menos gobierno?"
"Cree que el gobierno debe" —sobre todo si se usa un lenguaje tendencioso—
"¿Cree que el gobierno debe dar cupones?"
O, "¿Cree que el gobierno debe redistribuir?"
Entonces se puede ver un cambio radical partidista.
Pero al ser específicos, cuando realmente se pregunta
sobre los impuestos reales y temas de gastos que se estén estudiando,
las personas son notablemente centristas,
son llamativamente abiertas a transigir.
Así que lo que tenemos, entonces, cuando piensen en el abismo fiscal,
no piensen como si los estadounidenses fundamentalmente
no podemos soportarnos en estos temas
y que debemos ser desgarrados
en dos naciones beligerantes separadas.
Piensen en ello como un diminuto, pequeño número de economistas antiguos
y falaces ideólogos que han capturado el proceso.
Y han capturado el proceso a través de formas familiares,
a través de un sistema primario que fomenta
ese pequeño grupo de voces de la gente,
porque ese pequeño grupo de personas,
la gente que responde a todo sí o a todo no
sobre esas cuestiones ideológicas,
puede ser poca, pero cada uno de ellos tiene un blog,
cada uno de ellos ha estado en Fox o MSNBC en la última semana.
Cada uno de ellos se convierte en una voz más y más fuerte,
pero no nos representan.
No representan nuestros puntos de vista.
Y me lleva de vuelta al dólar,
me lleva a acordarme
que conocemos esta experiencia.
Sabemos qué es
tener a estas personas en la televisión, en el Congreso,
vociferando que viene el fin del mundo
si no adoptamos totalmente su punto de vista,
porque es lo que pasa con el dólar
desde que ha habido dólar.
Tuvimos la batalla entre Jefferson y Hamilton.
En 1913, tuvimos esta fea batalla sobre la Reserva Federal,
cuando se creó con argumentos maliciosos, molestos,
sobre cómo estaría constituida,
y el acuerdo general de que lo que se constituyó
fue el peor acuerdo posible,
un compromiso garantizado para destruir esta cosa valiosa,
este dólar, pero luego todo el mundo estuvo de acuerdo, está bien,
mientras estamos en el estándar de oro, debe estar bien.
La Fed no puede hacerlo tan mal.
Pero luego nos salimos del estándar de oro para los individuos
durante la Depresión y nos salimos del patrón oro
como fuente de coordinación internacional de la moneda
durante la presidencia de Richard Nixon.
Cada vez, estábamos al borde del colapso total.
Y no pasó nada en absoluto.
A lo largo de todo, el dólar ha sido
uno de las monedas más antiguas,
estables y razonables,
y todos lo usamos todos los días,
no importa lo que la gente esté gritando,
no importa lo asustados que se supone debemos estar.
Y este panorama fiscal a largo plazo en que estamos en este momento,
creo que lo más enloquecedor es que,
si el Congreso simplemente pudiera
mostrar que no están de acuerdo entre sí,
que no son capaces de idear el mejor acuerdo posible,
sino que son capaces de comenzar el proceso
de llegar a un acuerdo, todos estaremos mejor al instante.
El temor es que el mundo está mirando.
El temor es que cuanto más retrasemos cualquier solución,
el mundo verá a los EE.UU.
no como la piedra angular de la estabilidad en la economía mundial,
sino como un lugar que no puede resolver sus propias luchas,
y cuanto más tiempo demoramos, más ponemos al mundo nervioso,
las tasas de interés crecerán más,
más rápido vamos a tener que afrontar un día
de calamidad horrible.
Y así, solo el acto de ceder en sí mismo
y mantener un compromiso,
nos daría aún más tiempo,
permitiría a ambos lados diluir más el dolor
y llegar a ceder más en el camino.
Yo estoy en los medios. Siento que mi trabajo para que esto se dé,
es ayudar a fomentar las cosas que parecen llevar al compromiso,
no hablar de esto en esos términos vagos y atemorizantes
que nos polarizan,
sino solo hablar de esto como lo que es,
no es una crisis existencial,
no en una batalla entre dos visiones religiosas fundamentalmente diferentes,
sino un problema de matemáticas, un problema de matemáticas realmente resoluble,
uno donde no todos vamos a conseguir lo que queremos
y aquél en el que habrá un poco de dolor esparcido por ahí.
Pero cuanto más pronto lo afrontemos como un problema práctico,
antes podremos resolverlo,
y más tiempo tenemos para resolverlo, paradójicamente.
Gracias. (Aplausos)